sigue la inspección de la planta nuclear
de zaporilla dos de los expertos de loia
que llegaron ayer a las instalaciones se
quedarán de forma permanente con el
objetivo de monitorear la actividad de
la planta y evitar un accidente nuclear
en la central más grande de Europa la
visita de elohia ha sido largamente
esperada sin embargo para el gobierno
ucraniano faltó algo durante la primera
jornada
desafortunadamente no hemos escuchado lo
principal del oea que es el llamado a
Rusia para que desmilitarice la estación
qué podemos hacer sin él espero que la
misión cumpla con lo acordado por las
partes y que sirva a los intereses de
toda la comunidad internacional no
podemos ignorar el mayor riesgo
radiológico de los últimos 40 años no
podemos dejar a los soldados de un país
terrorista en la central
no solo Ucrania pide la
desmilitarización de la planta la ONU
también se ha sumado a este llamado ayer
el hoyea confirmó que la integridad
física de la central había sido violada
las instalaciones controladas por el
ejército ruso desde marzo han sido
escenario de varios ataques militares de
los que Moscú y kiev se han culpado
mutuamente el Ministerio de defensa ruso
acusó este viernes a Ucrania de
terrorismo nuclear y advirtió que la
situación podría desembocar en una
catástrofe para Europa a la vez aseguró
que no es Moscú quien aumenta ese riesgo
Afirma desde mi responsabilidad que no
tenemos armamento Pesado en el
territorio de la planta nuclear ni en
sus alrededores Espero que el Hoya pueda
verlo con sus propios ojos
la situación en saprilla sigue tensa y
los combates que se desarrollan a pocos
kilómetros tienen al mundo entero
conteniendo el aliento